[Musique]
dans cette clinique de Shanghai les
nouveaux-nés sont dorloté une équipe
d'expertes veille sur 15 bébés dans un
pays qui en fait de moins en moins le
taux de fécondité n'a jamais été aussi
bas en Chine 1,16 enfant par femme
contre 2,3 pour la moyenne mondiale
tu es trop mignon un bébé avec de grands
yeux
djangloo a fondé cette maternité de luxe
pour cette sage-femme la diminution des
naissances est alarmante
c'est inquiétant que les jeunes ne
veuillent plus avoir d'enfant parce que
le pays vieillit et ça crée une pression
sur la société
les autorités ont bien supprimé la
politique de l'enfant unique il y a 7
ans mais elle laisse encore des traces
si aujourd'hui les Chinois peuvent avoir
deux et même trois enfants pour beaucoup
c'est impensable
ce sera son seul bébé
pour l'instant je n'ai pas envisagé d'en
avoir un deuxième parce que la société
est assez cruelle avec les maires qui
travaillent ce n'est pas du tout facile
de s'occuper de soi-même de sa famille
et de sa carrière
en 2021 seul 10,6 millions de naissances
ont été enregistrés en Chine presque
moitié moins qu'il y a 10 ans en cause
le coût de l'éducation selon une étude
c'est 76000 euros en moyenne jusqu'à la
majorité l'un des montants les plus
élevés au monde alors avoir deux enfants
c'est un signe de richesse et c'est le
cas de la famille fou
c'était comment aujourd'hui on devait
faire un discours le thème c'était
qu'est-ce que tu ferais avec beaucoup
d'argent
Ryan et kale étudie dans l'un des
meilleurs collèges de la capitale 14000
euros l'année chacun et en dehors de
l'école leur emploi du temps est aussi
chargé aujourd'hui ces cours de code
il y a les cours de code et puis leurs
cours de danse les cours de dessin les
cours de maths et il y a les
entraînements de hockey au total ça
coûte à peu près 2800 euros par mois un
investissement pour en faire des
champions
là dedans il y a tout notre trophées et
tous nos diplômes
à 14 ans l'aîné cherche déjà
l'excellence
dans mon école la plupart des enfants
sont tous très forts ils travaillent dur
je ne suis pas aussi fort que j'ai
encore besoin de travailler beaucoup
pour les rattraper
avec un enfant de plus cette course à la
performance serait impossible
aujourd'hui pour donner une bonne
éducation à un enfant c'est vrai que ça
coûte cher c'est nécessaire parce que la
société actuelle est très compétitive je
ne pense pas être capable de bien
m'occuper d'un troisième enfant de ça
suffit
de la population pourrait menacer la
croissance chinoise et cela inquiète les
autorités pour l'ouverture du 20e
congrès sidine ping lui-même engage le
Parti communiste à s'attaquer au
problème
nous appliquerons des mesures politiques
pour stimuler le taux de natalité
et nous mènerons une stratégie nationale
pour répondre aux vieillissement de la
population
pour ce spécialiste c'est déjà trop tard
il alerte depuis des années sur
l'immense d'une crise démographique
les autorités ont entendu nos alertes
mais n'y ont pas cru ce qui a conduit à
une grave erreur de calcul les mesures
gouvernementales actuelles telles que la
construction d'un grand nombre de
crèches et l'octroi de quelques
allocations ne suffisent pas à stopper
la tendance à la baisse des naissances
le nombre de mariages s'effondre aussi
seulement 7,6 millions cette année un
minimum historique depuis 1986 la jeune
génération se marie plus tard ou pas du
tout au grand dames de leurs aînés ici
c'est le marché au mariage de Shanghai
des parents désespérés affichent les CV
de leur progéniture pour leur trouver
une âme sœur pour eux ne pas fonder de
famille c'est inconcevable
quand une fille grandit à l'âge de 24 ou
25 ans elle est censée trouver quelqu'un
se marier fonder une famille avoir des
enfants
à quoi sert une femme qui ne se marie
pas à 50 ans qui en voudra encore après
25 ans les femmes sont appelées Sean nu
soit les femmes périmées les jeunes
chinoises rejettent de plus en plus ces
étiquettes ce jean est Yolanda font
partie d'un collectif féminin d'entraide
professionnel leur carrière passe avant
le reste
je préfère avoir plus de temps pour
moi-même pour apprendre de nouvelles
connaissances ou développer plus de
compétences
un choix d'indépendance malgré la
pression sociale
ma mère m'a dit que pour qu'elle soit
comblée il faut que moi je me marie et
que j'ai des enfants donc ça me met une
pression énorme moi je n'envisage pas
d'avoir d'enfants et même si je me marie
un jour je veux vraiment être dans un
couple sans enfant
ce déclin des naissances accélère le
vieillissement de la population chinoise
un tiers des habitants aura plus de 60
ans d'ici 2035 et à la même date le
système des retraites devrait entrer en
déficit